they want all the upsides of global
capitalist markets and none of the
downsides so they want the global trade
they want the technology transfer they
want the capital flooding into the
country but they don't want to open
their markets to more um competitive
imports from the West right in a way
Trump was right right he was right in so
much as China gets lots of upside from
the global sort of economic compact very
little of the downside they know that
whereas in the west I think our ruling
Elites until very recently had this
strange f iCal idealistic view of
globalization that it had no downsides
oh it doesn't matter if that Local High
Street looks like a bomb's dropped on it
it doesn't matter that you've seen
de-industrialization and social anemy in
large parts of your country whether
that's South Wales the Rust Belt you
know bits of the English North East
doesn't matter in the end we're all
doing better the clever thing with the
Chinese Communist party is they never
fell prey to those
illusions